je pense que s'il vérifie que tout le
monde a un masque et les distances
nécessaires selon les groupes de
personnes je pense que ce serait parfait
parce que dans le métro on est collé on
est collé partout donc voilà il n'en
faudrait pas beaucoup je pense pour pour
qu'on se rende dans
un concert ben je dirais à des distances
de sécurité et sinon ouais bah je dirai
juste ça en fait je les mesures
sanitaires
je suis voilà après on peut toujours
bals et des concerts en faisant
attention et puis tout se passera bien
quoi mesures à prendre
il existe déjà un pour moi les salles
devraient déjà être ouverte donc
pourquoi est ce qu'on en voit dans les
tgv ce monde et où dans les avions et
part dans les salles de concerts ou les
salles de théâtre
voilà notre position est claire partage
absolument pas la vie et les mesures qui
sont prises par le gouvernement actuel
par la façon dont la crise est gérée
et effectivement je pense que les salles
de concerts pourrait ouvrir alors
personnellement des mesures je pense
qu'henri en variant les métro etc
je pense qu'un pas vraiment de solution
miracle pour les mesures puisque de
toute façon on n'est jamais vraiment un
mètre cinquante les uns des autres et
c'est donc je pense que ça changerait
pas et un concert ça changeait pas que
j'aie d'un métro vous voyez ce que je
veux dire donc je pense pas vraiment qui
est vraiment de solution miracle contre
le comte locaux vides à part se laver
les mains faire attention
rester chez soi le plus possible si
possible même si c'est très compliqué
voilà 80 comme la distanciation sociale
donc m rouverte et rouvrir les salles va
te répète beaucoup moins de monde mais
faire des concerts échelonnés pour les
gens qui allaient profiter du concert
déjà que le tour soit masqué jeu course
j'ai vu que potentiellement ils
voulaient tester avant les concerts et
après je pense que ça peut être bien en
tout cas de tester avant après après je
sais pas si ce serait nécessaire mais en
tout cas avant oui sûrement